today on the matte wall show rioting
raged in philadelphia for a second night
and spread to new york dc
elsewhere as usual the democrat leaders
of these cities did almost nothing to
stop but this is what you get from
democrats they sit and watch
while their cities burn also the victim
quote unquote of the police shooting
that sparked the riots
has a lengthy criminal record including
a horrible crime that he committed
against a woman
he's not the only blm martyr in the last
few months to have a history of abusing
women so why is it that blm celebrates
and canonizes men like this
and in our five headlines an explosive
tucker carlson
interview with the man blowing the
whistle on biden family corruption and
for our daily cancellation in perhaps my
most deserved
and necessary cancellation yet i will be
canceling
dancing all of that coming up but first
you know the fact is most people have a
balance on their credit cards and
they're paying a higher interest rate
than they should be
and that's money that they're just
throwing away there's no reason for it
get light stream instead you can
refinance
your high interest credit card balances
and save with a credit card
consolidation loan from lightstream
rates start at 5.59 apr with auto pay
and excellent credit
and the great thing is that the rate is
fixed so it'll never go up over the life
of the loan plus
even better there are no fees something
else keep in mind
you can get a loan from 5 000 to 100 000
and you can get your money
as soon as the day as you apply the day
you apply it's
that easy that simple that quick you've
got to take advantage of this
don't be like all the people that i've
seen get hamstrung
by debt preventing them from moving
forward in their lives we've all seen
this happen maybe it's happened to you
so listen to this part
my listeners can save even more with an
addition an additional interest rate
discount the only way to get this
discount is to go to lightstream.com
walsh l-i-g-h-t s-t-r-e-a-m.com
walsh subject credit approval rates
range from 5.95
apr to 19.99 apr and include a 0.5
auto pay discount lowest rate requires
excellent credit
terms and condition apply and offers are
subject to change without notice visit
lightstream.com
walls for more information well the
resurgence of black lives matter rioting
continued last night
spreading from philadelphia into new
york dc
new york was the second city in as many
nights to see cops run down
by rampaging motorists in philadelphia
uh chaos reigned across several city
blocks as dozens of stores were
ransacked everything from shoes to
large appliances were hauled away by
thieves looters even hit
chick-fil-a carted off i guess fistfuls
of ketchup packets and
chick-fil-a sauce and plastic forks and
this in spite of the fact that dan
cathy the ceo of chick-fil-a recently
got got on his knees
in front of an audience and shined a
black man's shoes
publicly in order to demonstrate his
racial enlightenment
yet they still looted his story just
goes to show once again that
you might as well retain your dignity
because it will profit you nothing to
forfeit
forfeit it anyway it's not it's not
going to accomplish what
you hope it accomplishes more tragically
some of the stores
had only recently in philadelphia that
had been looted had only recently
reopened after being decimated during
the first round of rioting
back in may and now these business
owners must rebuild all over again or
else
finally give up trying to do business in
communities
that will leap at the first opportunity
to pillage their shelves and take food
out of their children's mouths
in fact let's play a quick uh montage of
some of the action last night
if you missed it just for your reference
here it is
[Applause]
that's what i like
so there it is and and such is life
under a democrat mayor and governor
uh indeed pennsylvania governor tom wolf
has been
relentless in pursuing and punishing
dangerous degenerates who commit the
crime of
walking down the street without a mask
but is expectedly
less determined to do anything at all
about the looters currently terrorizing
his most populous city
speaking to reporters woof a man with
the distinct aura of a henpecked
substitute science teacher who can't
control his class
had this to say as everyone is
really sad by the the
death of of the victim and and i think
i share in mourning with the family
anytime that happens is a tragedy for
whatever reason
and i think we need to make sure that
that
we follow up find out what happened i'm
and my staff and have been in constant
communication since last night
with the folks in philadelphia and the
hope is that that
doesn't escalate into anything uh more
than the peaceful protests that
that i think this kind of situation
brings out
and the hope is that this doesn't
escalate into anything more than
peaceful protests
that this kind of situation brings out
it doesn't escalate into anything more
than peaceful protest
he made this statement of course
implying stating that it's peaceful
protest
he made the statement after rioters had
already spent the previous night looting
and burning
and at least one police officer had been
sent to the hospital with broken bones
this apparently qualifies as peaceful
protests it's not clear
what would need to happen in order to be
considered an escalation in tom wolf's
mind
whatever it is my guess is that the
rioters would have to change their
political affiliation and in many cases
probably their skin color
to earn a real rebuke from the governor
of the once proud
commonwealth of pennsylvania this is
what democrats do though when you elect
them to run your city or state
they simply sit back and they let it all
burn
chiming in occasionally to offer words
of encouragement to the people holding
the matches
we've seen this same plot unfold over
and over and over again
from from philly to new york to
minneapolis to kenosha to seattle and so
on
democrat leaders will not enforce the
law
in portland the police have been so
thoroughly gelded
that they're now reduced to tweeting
desperate pleas to rioters
the same writers who've held their city
hostage for half a year
now they have to tweet at them to get
them to stop on wednesday night the
portland pd twitter account
sent out this message very pitiful it
reads
uh to those marching on north denver
avenue please be mindful of those who
live in this community do not engage in
criminal behavior to include obstructing
vehicular traffic and
vandalizing private property we ask you
to encourage those who are engaged in
criminal
criminal behavior to stop shockingly
this does not appear to have deterred a
single lawbreaker
uh perhaps the police department will
have to pull out the big guns and start
tweeting angry gifts
at the anarchist next i don't know now
we could joke about this of course but
the consequences of democrat governance
are not funny
they are predictable and if you vote to
elect these people to lead you
everything that happens next all of the
chaos and destruction
that you had to know would come is your
fault partly
and you deserve it you quite literally
asked for it
these are the fruits of the trees you
planted
the only problem is that many others in
your city or state
who did not vote the same way but found
themselves outnumbered by these
self-destructive incredulous people like
you
must also reap what you have sown
now one other thing um related to the
philadelphia situation that i wanted to
mention
more information has come to light about
walter wallace jr who's the man who
approached
philly police while brandishing a knife
um
and whose seemingly justified death at
their hands has ostensibly
sparked the latest round of writing now
as uh as local abc affiliate in in the
city reports wallace was
an aspiring rapper whose quote central
themes in
his music were guns and shooting people
we're also told that he rapped about
social justice
it's uh it seems mysterious how someone
can be fascinated with shooting people
while being simultaneously concerned
with social justice but this is a
this is a needle that most rappers try
unsuccessfully to thread
now wallace has a lengthy rap sheet
he had a prior arrest for assaulting a
police officer it's not clear whether
the the officer is responding to the 911
call
shortly before his death knew about that
incident or not but more
noteworthy is his 2017 conviction for
robbery and assault reportedly
that crime involved kicking down the
door of another woman and putting a gun
to her head
now this sounds familiar that's because
george floyd was convicted of doing
almost exactly the same thing except in
his case
he forced his way into a woman's home
and put a gun to her stomach rather than
her head
so wallace's actions are reminiscent of
things we've already seen including
jacob blake who allegedly broke into a
woman's house raped her
then stole her debit card in her vehicle
if you're keeping track at home
that makes three recent blm martyrs with
a history
in two cases confirmed in one case very
credibly alleged
of brutalizing and abusing women in
unspeakable ways
we could also add to the list ricardo
munoz uh who's the man
shot by lancaster police after charging
at them with a knife he had several
previous
convictions the worst one being a recent
spree where he stabbed four people
including a minor and a 22 year old
woman though he did appear to be an
equal opportunity felon
uh in fairness stabbing men and women
alike
now all of these men have been
performatively
mourned the names of at least two of
them and now probably three when walter
wallace has added to it have graced the
helmets of
nfl players they've been memorialized
as heroes of their community joe biden
infamously visited with the credibly
accused rapist
jacob blake's family and spoke with
blake himself on the phone
and complimented him afterwards last
night biden tweeted out his heartbreak
over the death of wallace and while
we're implored to say the names of these
men
and celebrate their lives and weep over
their deaths or
injuries in blake's case their female
victims are erased from the discussion
uh their names are not mentioned or
allowed to be mentioned
their suffering does not count nobody
ever stops to ask
how they must feel to see their abusers
lauded in this way
nobody asks for their perspective and if
they were to offer it they'd be shouted
down
or worse and we all know that this is
what blm and the democrat party thinks
of women who
don't fit neatly into the script don't
cooperate with the program
mostly they think nothing of them they
don't acknowledge their existence
and we're expected to follow that lead
making the violent criminals into
victims but never speaking a word about
the victims of the violent criminals
it is by this silence that the left
crafts and maintains its narrative
so i say we should not be silent
about it anymore let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
you know there are a lot of companies
out there who don't share our values
and are working against us in the
culture even as we give them
our money they use our money partly to
to work against us
that's why when we find companies who
share the same values as us i think we
need to
support them and that's why i can't
recommend highly enough
uh the pro-life phone company charity
mobile look five percent of your monthly
plan
will go to the pro-life pro-family
charity of your choice so you get to
decide
and your money's going to go there uh
hopefully you have other charitable
endeavors that you do but this is a
really great thing to add to that
and at the same time while you're adding
to your
charitable endeavors and supporting a
great company you're also getting a
wonderful service a
new account new activations and eligible
accounts get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping
there's no contracts there's no
termination fees there's no risk with a
30-day guarantee so they're not roping
you into something you can't get out of
um not that you would want to get out of
it anyway there's the live
customer service based in the usa and
plus you've got the ability to
to block use of cellular data picture
messages
text messages so you know if you got a
kid with a phone then you can
protect them that way as well which is
really important free usage alerts
free apps to monitor your usage to pay
your bills
a much much more but again this this for
me goes back to
uh you know we're helping to build a
culture of life in america while
supporting a pro-life company
and it's it's a win it's the classic
win-win you're getting a good service
good
product uh supporting a company that
needs to be supported
so call charity mobile at 1-877-474-3662
or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com okay an explosive
and important interview with tony
babilinski on tucker carlson last night
he's a former hunter biden
business associate who has now come out
as a whistleblower
exposing the corruption he came out
after the laptop story to confirm that
the emails there are real
there was quite a lot in this interview
we can't play all of it obviously but
here's i think
the headline listen to this i'm thinking
about
the biden family like how are they doing
this
i know joe decided not to run in 2016
but what if he
ran in the future aren't they taking
political risk or headline risk
and i remember looking at jim biden and
saying how are you guys
getting away with this like or aren't
you concerned
and he sort of looked at me and he
laughed a little bit and said
plausible deniability he said that out
loud
uh yes he said it directly to me one on
one in a cabana at the peninsula hotel
after about a you know hour and a half
two hour meeting
with me asking out of concern how are
you guys doing this
aren't you concerned that you're going
to put your brother's your future
presidential campaign at risk
um you know the chinese the stuff that
you guys have been doing already in 2015
and 2016 around the world
and uh i just can almost picture his
face where he sort of chuckles and says
you know plausible deniability so he
said this is a man who's been drafting
off his brother's political career for
almost 50 years
he said to your face essentially we're
lying about it
anyone watching this interview can look
up what plausible deniability means
and the definition is very distinct of
course you know i call that the headline
but it's only the headline
if you're an honest person who cares
about what's really happening in the
world
and you want to talk about actual news
that matters that then it's then it's a
headline
as far as our media is concerned there
was no headline
from that interview because the
interview never happened
instead i woke up this morning and uh
you know the the headline that i saw the
media talking about
was trump had a rally i guess in omaha
and some people had trouble getting home
from the rally because there was a
problem with the shuttle buses
and so there were some people that were
very cold outside trying to get back
from the rally
and this is a this is this is headline
news more than
more than what we just heard evidence of
real corruption
in the biden family no people having
trouble on a shuttle bus getting back
from a trump rally which by the way
is trump's fault because donald trump
has the president united states
and the and the presidential candidate
is supposed to be working out the
logistics
of getting people to and from he's
supposed to be the one on the phone you
know calling the bus company
i'm sure that's what joe biden does
right no in fact well joe biden doesn't
have to as we move on to number two here
nice transition because joe biden
doesn't have to worry about bus
buses to his rallies because he could
fit everybody in his rally into like a
honda accord
um here's uh he had a rally in georgia
if you can even call it that here's the
footage
it's the saddest thing i've ever seen in
my life am i supposed to be depressed
when i see a politician's rally is that
is that the
the vibe that joe biden's going for
because that's how i feel
and if he's going for that he absolutely
nails it
brilliantly so you can take a look at
this there he is walking down the steps
there's the rally
uh you see all the people they're in
they've got these circles
painted on the ground and they all stay
in their circle
and there's a fire pit in the middle for
some reason
honestly if i saw this without any
context
at all i would assume that it's some
weird
cult thing you must stay in the circle
the circle must not not be breached i
would assume it's something like that
people of the circle i would just maybe
i'd guess it would be the name of the
cult i don't know
um and i i guess i wouldn't be too far
off actually in reality
it is a little bit of a weird cult thing
now people ask if you know you see these
things
and this is at all a lot of biden's
rallies where they got the circles and
everybody has to stay in the circle
and there's you know there's there's 14
people at the rally they're all in their
little circle
and the question is why do you need the
circles on the ground you spread the
chairs out why do you need to put
circles around it
and uh well there's two reasons for it
number one this is this is virtue
signaling this is signaling see but
we're we're taking
we are unlike donald trump we're taking
chronovirus very seriously look we spray
painted circles on the ground
that's how seriously we take it but also
it's supposed to be an excuse
for the low turnout and what they're
doing is they're advertising to anyone
who sees it they're saying
you see we could only fit so many people
in the circles we only had look
we only had 12 circles to go even though
we spray painted them we could have but
you know we had we only had enough spray
paint for 12 circles that's why there's
only 12 people
there's there's six thousand other
people that wanted them to come but they
couldn't
that's why they make the circles there
okay number three amy coney barrett has
only been a supreme court justice for a
day but already she's generating
controversy um
here's the headline in the hill justice
aimee coney barrett
to use supreme court chambers formerly
occupied by the late ruth bader ginsburg
so she's going to be in rbg's chambers
and if you read comments on social media
a fair number of people are upset about
this
because of course it's horribly
offensive for her to use
the great rbg's chambers how dare she
how dare she use
now i'm not really sure what she's
supposed to do they don't i assume they
only have so many
like they've got one for each justice
so of course she's what are they gonna
do build her new chambers and then
keep the mummified remains of rbg and
her old
seal it you know like a like a pyramid
egyptian style is that
is that what they want in fact i i think
unironically the left would expect that
because we've also heard that not only
has
amy coney barrett stolen uh
rbg's spot on the supreme court now she
steals her offices
she's also stolen initials this is
something you see a lot that
when we call amy coney barrett acb we
shouldn't do that
because we only do that for rbg
rbg invented initials no one had
initials before her
how dare acb steal those
what a leech appropriating um number
four
pizza hut is the latest fast food joint
to end racism so this is also pretty big
news i'd say
you know i think anytime racism is ended
i i think it's something we should pay
attention to and
racism has ended every single day by by
another corporation
and then it starts up again and then so
someone else has to come and end it
again so it's this constant it's like a
whack-a-mole sort of thing
but uh here's the delaware says pizza
hut has teamed up with a non-profit
social enterprise developing guidelines
to quote
correct implied and overt forms of bias
and privilege
in teaching methods and classroom
materials the 46-page training manual is
advertised as an introduction
to anti-racist pedagogy pedagogy
guiding guiding teachers who seek to
increase their personal awareness on the
subject
leading experts in the anti-bias
anti-racist field
are said to have informed the content
which encourages educators to
incorporate
those visions into lesson plans okay
well that's good
um because you know when i think of
pizza hut
the first thing i think is um this is a
company
whose primary goal is to correct implied
and over
overt forms of bias and privilege
that's the first thing i think of when i
think of pizza
and you know it might really be because
i certainly don't think of pizza for
pizza hut
um i mean if you
if you like cart if you like to have
tomato sauce on
on cardboard with old cheese on top if
that's your thing then pizza hut
certainly is
the way to go all right let's go to
number five and
probably we've done a lot of big story
probably the biggest story
of you know the year kim kardashian
turned 40.
so happy birthday to her even though i
cancelled birthdays i'll make an
exception kim kardashian she can have
one
because she's famous and rich and
important so obviously they are
exceptions
um a lot of people are upset about her
social media posts relating to her
birthday
and this is what she posted let's go
through this
so on twitter she says 40 and feeling so
humbled and blessed
this is not there's not a single day
that i take for granted especially
during these times when we are all
reminded of the things that truly matter
and there she is posing with her uh with
her friends
for my birthday party this year i
couldn't think of a better way to spend
it than with some of my the people who
have helped shape me into the woman i am
today
before covid i don't think any of us
truly appreciated what a simple luxury
was to be able to travel and be together
with family and friends in a safe
environment after two weeks of multiple
health screens and asking everyone to
quarantine
i surprised my closest inner circle with
a trip to a private island where we
could pretend things were normal just
for a brief moment in time
uh we danced rode bikes swam near wales
kayaked watched a movie on the beach and
so much more
i realized that for most people this is
something that is so far out of reach
right now
so in moments like these i am humbly
reminded of how privileged my life is i
like how she says
this is so far out of reach right now
like for most of us
it's yeah you know i can't really swing
the the two-week trip to the private
island this year
can't really do it you know i had to cut
back on a few things had to cut out the
private island trip
so i can keep three or four of my
mansions that was kind of hard to choose
um now a couple things here number one
a lot of this is my own personal health
routine uh you know
i dance and swim at the whales three
times a week it's just a normal fitness
thing i thought everybody did that
number two my only real problem when i
see this
is the bit about watching a movie on the
beach
seems like the kind of thing you do for
the social media picture
but otherwise why would you i can't
think of a of a worse place to watch
obviously the acoustics are are not good
or non-existent
you're on the beach you got the waves
crashing you're sitting in the sand
what's the advantage of watching a movie
on the beach as opposed to just going
into your house
i assume she has a house with a home
theater with a with a really nice home
theater system
so if i went to kim kardashian's
birthday party
which i doubt i'd be invited but if i
was i would attend and she said we're
gonna watch a movie i'd be excited
thinking oh we're gonna go watch it on a
you know
100 foot whatever and then she said oh
no we're going to watch it on tv on the
beach i'd be i'd be pretty upset about
that
most people though are upset i guess
this this
post caused controversy because she's
rich
and she can do this and how dare she
flaunt it um that's not the part that
upsets me personally i
uh you know i tend to think if you're
rich enough
if i was rich enough i'd go into private
island too so we can't blame her for
that
although we can't blame her for
celebrating a birthday in general
because has has been established
birthdays are cancelled all right we're
gonna get to our speaking of being of
cancelling things we're gonna get to our
daily cancellation in just a second but
before we do
you know it's really important to hedge
your investments with gold but it's also
expensive
not as expensive as a private island but
still expensive for most of us who are
not kim kardashian to just go out and
buy gold so here's something new
you know how the price of gold has been
skyrocketing lately now there's a new
way to buy gold through a company called
acre acre lets you subscribe to gold
gold bars for as little as 30 bucks a
month you pay each month and once your
gold stash reaches the price of their
gold bars
they just discreetly ship acre gold to
your house
and you know it's safe because acres
going to take care of it they're going
to send it to you
there's not going to be any big
advertisement that it's gold obviously
you wouldn't want that
they ship it directly to your house and
with acre taking
physical delivery of your gold means
that it's safe and you know you can you
can rely on that acre designs their gold
in california sources their gold from
one of the largest mints in switzerland
acre provides industry-first packaging
that looks and feels
more expensive than other gold
alternatives acre just recently
introduced their new 100
per month subscription for their five
gram gold bar so you can also take
advantage of that visit
get acre gold dot com slash walsh and
start investing in physical gold today
make sure you go go to this url and go
now because acre's also giving away a
gold bar
they're giving one away so to qualify
for the giveaway
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient
of a gold bar be very creative in your
submission mention at
get underscore acre and maybe you'll get
a free one but otherwise still
go to get acre gold dot com slash walsh
and thank you to acre gold for
supporting
the show let's get to our daily
cancellation so this will be a short
cancellation today only because i think
it should be so self-explanatory that i
hardly need to justify the cancellation
well i suppose i shouldn't have to
justify any cancellation or anything
else as a theocratic fascist dictator my
edicts must simply be implemented and
obeyed
it is not to question why it is but to
do and die but in any case today i am
canceling
dancing i have long been a fierce critic
of dancing on the grounds that it is
the devil's language the bad guys in
footloose
had it right all along in my opinion but
this year in particular has made the
matter of dancing
unmistakably clear the final straw for
me with dancing
was this video which was posted this
week watch
we're on the rise it's mine and when
time to rise
you say bye to joe joe
when i say joe you say bye to joe
joe
[Music]
so we can't believe
now if you're listening to the podcast
you couldn't see the dancing which is
fortunate for you but suffice it to say
that the woman dancing to the joe biden
song
was dancing exactly as you would expect
someone to dance to a joe biden song
and that's not really a criticism of her
there's only so much you can do with
that kind of material
and if this was the only offense that
dancing had committed this year
i might just cancel the joe biden song
and leave dancing alone
but there is so much more so for example
donald trump okay this is bipartisan
donald trump in recent weeks has taken
to dancing during his campaign rallies
and um here's what that looks like
it's is
now he's of course dancing to the ymca
which is maybe the one single dance that
uncoordinated goofy dudes
such as donald trump and myself can
actually perform
though the transition from m to c is a
bit tricky and i've twice dislocated my
shoulder attempting it
but even so it's about as easy as
dancing gets
yet trump has elected horrifyingly to
freestyle the ymca
and the results are are tragic
and i fear that our enemies might watch
that clip and conclude that they both
can and must invade and enslave us and
i'm not sure i disagree
in fact my greatest criticism of the
trump administration generally
has been its dancing um remember sean
spicer and dancing with the stars
watch watch this again
everything's free
[Music]
[Music]
nobody should have to see this my son
saw that clip and broke down in tears
and said daddy
why did that man make a blouse out of a
traffic safety vest and then have a
seizure on stage while a woman twirled
around him
and i said son this is what happens when
people dance
this this again is not a partisan issue
in fact carol baskin
a woman famous for probably killing her
husband was on dancing with the stars
this season and the results were
nearly as abominable and we know about
the dancing nurses
who plague who plagued tick-tock nearly
uh very early on in the pandemics
staging elaborate dance routines in the
middle of the hospitals
in order to convince us to take the
virus seriously so what more evidence do
we need
and you know aside from the the the
dancing related
atrocities that have been committed
throughout history
especially this past year perhaps the
more salient point
is that dancing serves no discernable
purpose
even in the context of celebration or
or uh or or recreation i can't
understand the point
whenever we go to a wedding my wife
always asks why i don't go out on the on
the floor and dance and i explain that
the reception hall has
chairs and tables and food and beer
why would i dance when i can literally
sit in a chair
and drink and eat it's like if i'm
watching tv and you come in and ask
ask me why i'm not out in the rain
standing on my head
because there's why would i the
alternative activity which i'm currently
engaged in
is preferable in every way and in every
sense
that's why i actually kind of enjoyed it
last year when i tore my achilles
and we had a wedding a few months later
one of my friends at a wedding we
went to nobody could expect me to dance
i had every excuse to sit on my fat ass
gorging myself like a self-respecting
man so here's what it comes down to
the average human spends 96 hours a year
dancing according to my estimates now
add up all the hours humanity has spent
dancing just in the last decade we're
talking literally
trillions of hours of it um the vast
majority upwards of 30
73 again by my estimates being done by
people who don't even have any rhythm
now some scientists have warned that if
not for dancing we would have already
cured cancer
we would currently be colonizing pluto
that's what dancing has gotten us and i
think
it's time for us to move on from it and
leave these
primitive forms of expression and
recreation
on the ash heap of history where they
belong
and that's why dancing is now canceled
not a lot of dance anymore
but you know i i think the majority of
people who do dance only do it out of
social pressure anyway
so i think you're probably more relieved
than anything to hear that it's
it's canceled i think dancing is one of
those things that we've been doing
as a species and nobody knows exactly
why
and 90 of us hate it and wish that
everyone would stop
well now it's stopped you're welcome
and that's going to do it for the show
today thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
a whistleblower exposes deep corruption
in the biden family
can i change my vote trends on google
and a wife
becomes a lesbian to stay married to her
transgender husband
check it out on the michael knowles show